Hey! This is your travel host, Naomi.
I'd like to give you a tour of the top 10 attractions of Paris.
Number 10: Hotel de Ville.
This grand, Neo-Renaissance style landmark built centuries ago is home of the city administration.
Number 9: Place de la Concorde.
The largest square in Paris.
It has a 3000-year-old Egyptian obelisk and is particularly beautiful at night.
Number 8: The Pompidou Center.
A colorfully creative, modern building housing a vast collection of modern art.
Number 7: Arc de Triomphe.
Built in the early 1800s by Napoleon, the Arc is a symbol of national pride.
At the top, you'll find fantastic views of Paris.
Number 6 is the Seine boat cruise.
It's affordable, convenient, and in a short period of time,...
...you can see many major landmarks of the city.
Number 5: Versailles Palace.
A royal chateau just outside of Paris has grand architectures,...
...700 rooms, and beautiful gardens.
Number 4: Notre Dame.
One of the most recognized symbols in the world and over 750 years old,...
...Notre Dame has incredibly detailed Gothic architecture.
Number 3: Sacre-Coeur.
This Byzantine style, stunning white church,...
...despised by intellectuals when it was built, is a must-see for Paris visitors.
Number 2: The Louvre Museum.
Perhaps the world's most famous museum,...
...it hosts thousands of pieces of great art including Leonardo Da Vinci's Mona Lisa.
And number 1 is the Eiffel Tower.
Amongst the most recognizable and visited monuments in the world,...
...everyone must experience the Eiffel Tower in their lifetime.
Keep watching our travel series. Ciao!